joining us now is dj taylor writer and
george orwell biographer hello thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning totalitarian
might upset some people what he was
depicting what do you think he'd make of
that
um
judging what orwell would have made of
anything 72 years after his death is is
not much of a runner but i think
um what what amuses me i suppose about
this is where that decision came from
because as far as i can make out
no student at the university of
northampton had actually complained
about this it was a decision taken by
supposedly somewhat fearful academics
and so many of the custodians of culture
and academia rather fearful at the
moment and i think they it was a case of
sort of trying to get in and prevent
trouble before it actually happened um
you know so if any student had
complained i suppose i'd be slightly
more sympathetic towards this than i am
at the moment
um
i suppose if we start along this road
there'll be an awful lot of books that
we'll need to put on um give trigger
warnings
i think that's a very good point um i
mean i can see why if you were if you
were a secondary school teacher with a
class of 13 year olds and this was on
the syllabus you might say to them there
is material in here that you may when
you come across it fine disturbing and
upsetting and it's that cage of rats
that people always complain about in the
winston-smith interrogation scenes but
by the time you come to be an
undergraduate i think you have to accept
that if you're studying english or any
other kind of literature part of the
point of a great deal of it is that it
is challenging and potentially offensive
and it's up to you to be able to get
your head around that and if you're not
comfortable with that then it's possible
that the literature is not the kind of
thing that you ought to be studying
and certainly spoiler alert stay away
from clockwork orange um 1984 famously
warns of a of a heavily censored world
there's a certain irony there
there is a great irony but this is th
this is this is what always happens with
book with books of that nature uh the
idea that you're you're prophesying that
might something that might actually come
to to affect your your own works um it's
interesting quite one interesting thing
is to give it a bit of historical
context and i i certainly know from my
own researchers that when that book was
in proof you know a couple of months
before it was being issued uh in the
summer of 1949 uh there were occasions
there was an occasion when it was it was
presented and advanced copies were given
to a collection of booksellers who would
hope it was hope would stock it in their
shops um and they were absolutely
terrified and you know the reports back
of you know middle-aged men being given
nightmares i'm told that my grandmother
when she watched the first bbc
dramatization of it in the early 1950s
was absolutely terrified but of course
this was over nearly 70 years ago and i
think possibly um you know most pop the
public taste has perhaps got a little
more sophisticated since then so i i
you don't like pigs walking on the back
legs you're not gonna like animal farm
either it's good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the program